happiness is a byproduct not an actual
destination and so people have this
misconception that they're going to find
happiness like it's Europe and they're
never going to move out happiness is a
byproduct of certain behaviors and you
can set yourself up to win and you can
set yourself up to be happy the sad
thing is happiness is a learned skill
and a lot of our houses don't teach
happiness that was the situation I was
in and so I actually started studying
people that were happy and I felt what
the algorithm was what do they do that's
similar and for me I don't focus on
happiness as much as harmony I don't
really believe in the word balance
because balance is a binary thing it's
like oh you it's a very you know tedious
like a harmony is saying my life has
many components I'm a woman I'm a mom I
am sexual I'm spiritual and a business
person all of those winds have to have
tone and that brings about harmony that
brings about satisfaction if you only
have one limb that is very buff and the
rest of this is atrophied we have
disharmony we have dissatisfaction but
there's no human school and so that's
what I'm looking at starting I want to
be able to teach people emotional and
mindfulness skills so that they can
bring gain tone in every area from my
standpoint you know since you all took
it up here I will take it into one very
narrow place that I've been really
trying to spend a lot of time on and
that's perspective it's so interesting
to me why I deem myself happy because I
just am so grateful like things like the
thing we got excited about of you know
the data the data behind being human
being is 400 trillion to 1 when you just
start there and you realize forget about
the odds of like feeding homeless
insulin-like other like or being born in
a communist country like just actually
becoming a human like like I always make
the joke of like your mom could have had
another glass of wine and like like you
know like like for your dad good been
late and late because I'm a traveler the
odds are so insane I'm just so grateful
for what I have versus what I don't have
and I think people just have all these
admirations and envy and all these hard
wiring things a community perspective
just like there's hope I just genuinely
believe there's always somebody that has
it worse and the problem is that's where
I default into mentally and a practice
to put myself there versa
if somebody's got it better
[Music]